welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with this a lot of angry people in
California where are hundreds of
thousands of people in that state could
be without power for days in the largest
public safety outage in that state's
history PG&E started shutting off the
power last night more than half of
California's 58 counties because of what
the company calls an unprecedented
wildfire danger
roughly 800,000 customers are likely to
be affected Jonathan Vigliotti is in
Santa Rosa that's about 50 miles north
of San Francisco and Jonathan I
understand the neighborhood you're in
was destroyed by wildfires just two
years ago yeah that's correct good
morning to you Tony it's taken two years
and you could still see many of the
homes in this neighborhood under
construction I've spoken with a lot of
people and for that reason they
understand the need for this power cut
but they do worry how they're gonna get
by for the next few days in the dark at
this hour we could tell you more than
200,000 homes are already without
electricity wind gusts expected to pick
up to 50 miles per hour for now PG&E
playing it safe this is what PG&E hopes
will never happen again a wildfire
sparked by faulty transmission lines and
fueled by high winds devastated the town
of Paradise killing 85 and destroying
almost 19,000 buildings last November
PG&E is facing billions in liability for
that fire this time the state's largest
energy provider can't afford to take any
chances no matter how long it takes I
can't expect that we may not have power
in certain areas for up to seven days
sometimes I feel like we're being
punished by PG&E you know because of all
the lawsuits in 2017 that mazzani's
coffee park neighborhood
burned to the ground that fire sparked
by a private electrical system that's a
mess I mean it was a few chimney
standing that was about it there's
nothing else left what do you think
about their proposal to turn off
electricity it's just something new that
people are gonna have to get used to a
new reality
meteorologist Mike Peck nur agrees the
winds in this case will be around 55
miles an hour but they're strong enough
to take down line so you can't take away
the oxygen and you can't take away the
fuels but you can't take away the
ignition source meanwhile the mayor of
Oakland warned that power lines aren't
the only way fires get started
do not use equipment that may cause
sparks be extremely cautious if you are
a smoker it might be a good week to quit
and PG&E says they're planning billions
of dollars in safety upgrades that could
take four years they're already saying
that could bring significant increases
to bills and Anthony as you can imagine
customers saying they already pay a lot
of money for what should be safe power
yeah John with some things a new reality
not an easy reality there